Sister Wives star mckelty padron is
officially a mom of twins Cody and
Christine's daughter announced the
exciting news with these sweet snaps she
and her husband Tony welcomed Sons
Archer and Ace on November 17th the
little ones born two minutes apart
there's grandma Christine holding the
twins grinning ear to ear love living in
Utah close to my kids it's been fabulous
also there to welcome michelty's twins
Christine's former sister wife Robin
which comes as no surprise because she
is close to mckelty we're going to
record y'all you know so we were just I
saw them Robin and Cody at a family
event recently mckelvey's baby shower
and they came and everything and
I was a little bit not sure but we were
fine mckelty and Tony are already
parents to one-year-old daughter Avalon
whose home birth was featured on the
current season of the TLC Series
yeah fans got a full glimpse of
Christine becoming a grandma once again
as she and Robin stopped by mckelty's
side as she gave birth to her baby girl
as far as having only my mom Christine
and my mom Robin I just I'm a lot closer
to those two and I'm a lot more bonded
to those two than I am too Janelle or
Mary I'm just I'm not close to them and
I wanted to make sure that my birth was
very much about selfishly I want my
birth to be about me and for Christine
witnessing her kids become parents is
special so Avalon ASAP padron is now
born
and oh my gosh she's beautiful
it's really one of the most humbling
things to watch in this life and that
baby is going to have the best parents
I'm just excited for the rest of their
adventure together and now mckelty and
Tony have two more little bundles of joy
to join their Adventure congrats to the
[Music]